Speaker 1: . Yesterday, we talked about the
completely bogus conspiracy theory that spread
like wildfire this weekend, that Joe Biden
wants to take away red meat and even plant
based will force plant based beer on people,
which we know of as beer as part of his climate
plan.
And the talking point included that Joe Biden's
climate plan would reduce each American's
so-called meat allowance to four pounds of
red meat per year.
We already talked about it yesterday.
It's completely false.
But that didn't stop endless tweets and TV
segments about it.
Congresswoman Lauren Bobert tweeted about
it and just accepted the premises hook, line
and sinker.
Donald Trump Jr. tweeted about it.
And indeed, the source on this stuff was listed
on air on Fox News as the Department of Agriculture
of the University of Michigan.
Now, as I told you yesterday, this is a study
of hypothetical changes from the University
of Michigan from last year, from before Joe
Biden even being president.
It has nothing to do with Joe Biden's plan,
which is simply the study simply said if people
did X, the result on emissions would be Y
has nothing to do with Joe Biden whatsoever.
Now, Fox News anchor John Roberts admitted
on air yesterday that he pushed a completely
baseless claim on Friday.
I call this lying about Joe Biden trying to
require Americans to reduce meat consumption
as part of his climate plan.
Here is the apology, which, of course, makes
no mention of the fact that there were three
days of news coverage and apoplectic Republicans
which were catalyzed by the pathetic segment
that John Roberts did on Friday.
Here is the retraction, if you want to call
it that.
Speaker 7: On Friday, we told you about a
study from the University of Michigan to give
some perspective on President Biden's ambitious
climate change goals.
That research from twenty twenty found that
cutting back how much red meat people eat
would have a drastic impact on harmful greenhouse
gas emissions.
The data was accurate, but a graphic and a
script incorrectly implied that it was part
of Biden's plan for dealing with climate change.
That is not the case.
Speaker 1: OK, so at least he took it back.
But the retraction is sort of convoluted and
quick.
It barely even really mentions what happened
and the damage is done.
The genie is out of the bottle.
You can't unring the bell.
Very few people see the correction.
It's much too late and it's almost the strategy.
They will knowingly make ten ridiculous claims
about Democrats, Biden, Obama, the left.
They know that they're false.
Some they will get called out on one might
explode so badly that three days later they
do a take back.
But they've succeeded overall at getting the
talking points out.
They spend hours on multiple programs all
weekend making the same accusations.
And then on Monday you get one short retraction.
Remember that Judge Jeanine Pirro covered
the same story.
Remember these clips?
I played them for you yesterday.
Speaker 8: Finally tonight, do you like red
meat?
So the cows must go?
Yeah, I like burgers and I like my gas powered
car, and I'm sick of China having the upper
hand over us.
Speaker 1: What about Judge Jeanine's retraction?
Even if she does want.
It's only a weekly show.
She's not back until the weekend.
It's almost perfect.
You tell the lie Friday afternoon, you set
off a weekend of coverage.
You quietly retracted on Monday on one show
only.
And by then, millions of right wingers believe
that Don Jr has tweeted about it.
They've all signaled, boosted it, and nothing
comes of the attempt.
And it's pretty flaccid as far as an attempt
goes to correct the record.
What John Roberts did was lie.
And it's a retraction.
It's convoluted, but that is what he is in
practice actually admitting to here.
And of course, we knew the story was false
all along.
There just was nothing
to it.